[Music]
the universe began its cosmic life in a
big bang nearly 14 billion years ago and
has been expanding ever since but what
is it expanding into that's a
complicated question here's why
Einstein's equations of general
relativity describe space and time as a
kind of interconnected fabric for the
universe this means that what we know of
as space and time exists only as part of
the universe and not beyond it now when
everyday objects expand they move out
into more space but if there is no such
thing as space to expand into what does
expanding even mean in 1929 Edwin
Hubble's astronomy observations gave us
a definitive answer his survey of the
night sky found all faraway galaxies
recede or move away from the earth
moreover the further the galaxy the
faster it recedes how can we interpret
this consider a loaf of raisin bread
rising in the oven the batter rises by
the same amount between each and every
raisin
if we think of raisins as a stand-in for
galaxies and batter as the space between
them we can imagine that the stretching
or expansion of intergalactic space will
make the galaxies recede from each other
and for any galaxy it's far away
neighbors will recede a larger distance
than the nearby ones in the same amount
of time
sure enough the equations of general
relativity predict a cosmic tug-of-war
between gravity and expansion it's only
in the Dark Void between galaxies where
expansion wins out and space stretches
so there's our answer the universe is
expanding unto itself
that said cosmologists are pushing the
limits of mathematical models to
speculate on what if anything exists
beyond our space-time these aren't wild
guesses but hypotheses that tackle kinks
in the scientific theory of the Big Bang
the Big Bang predicts matter to be
distributed evenly across the universe
as a sparse gas but then how did
galaxies and stars come to be the
inflationary model describes a brief era
of incredibly rapid expansion there
relates quantum fluctuations in the
energy of the early universe to the
formation of clumps of gas that
eventually led to galaxies if we accept
this paradigm it may also imply our
universe represents one region in a
greater cosmic reality that undergoes
endless eternal inflation we know
nothing of this speculative inflating
reality save for the mathematical
prediction that it's endless expansion
may be driven by an unstable quantum
energy state in many local regions
however the energy may settle by random
chance into a stable state stopping
inflation and forming bubble universes
each bubble universe ours being one of
them would be described by its own Big
Bang and laws of physics our universe
would be part of a greater multiverse in
which the fantastic rate of eternal
inflation makes it impossible for us to
encounter a neighbour universe the Big
Bang also predicts that in that early
hot universe our fundamental forces may
unify into one super force mathematical
string theories suggest descriptions of
this unification in addition to a
fundamental structure for subatomic
quarks an electro
in these proposed models vibrating
strings are the building blocks of the
universe computing model for Strings
have now been consolidated into a
unified description as suggests these
structures may interact with massive
higher dimensional surfaces called
brains our universe may be contained
within one such brain floating in an
unknown higher dimensional place
playfully named the bulk or hyperspace
other brains containing other types of
universes may coexist in hyperspace and
neighboring brains may even share
certain fundamental forces like gravity
both eternal inflation and brains
describe a multiverse but while universe
is an eternal inflation our isolated
brain universes could bump into each
other an echo of such a collision may
appear in the Cosmic Microwave
Background a soup of radiation
throughout our universe it's a relic
from the early Big Bang era so far
though we found no such cosmic echo some
suspect these differing multiverse
hypotheses may eventually coalesce into
a common description or be replaced by
something else as it stands now their
speculative explorations of mathematical
models while these models are inspired
and guided by many scientific
experiments there are very few objective
experiments to directly test them yet
until the next Edwin Hubble comes along
scientists will likely be left to argue
about the elegance of their competing
models and continue to dream about what
if anything lies beyond our universe one
of our favorite things about the ted-ed
community is our shared passion for big
sometimes unanswerable questions
students in our ted-ed clubs program for
example are using the TED platform to
explore big questions like would robots
make good judges
where does confidence come from and why
is my cat penny so small if you're
between 8 and 18 years old we want you
to share your big question or big idea
with Ted visit ed tech
slash clubs to get started